rando pays vous emmène cette semaine à
cilaos pour une petite randonnée
accessible à tous le sentier des sources
au dessus du village de bras sec
rendez-vous à cilaos direction bras sec
après avoir dépassé le bloc et la forêt
de cryptomerias vous pourrez vous garer
sur ce parking de mara joseph
gp
notre accompagnateur jérôme turpin 2ème
réunion nous propose une petite balade
très facile juste à côté de cette zone
de pique nique très fréquenté de cilaos
youtube
en partant comme pour gravir le rempart
du kerveguen une bifurcation sur la
droite permet d'emprunter le sentier des
sources en direction de bras sec
certainement l'une des balades les plus
faciles du cirque de cilaos avec la
roche merveilleuse
la seule difficulté de ce sentier en
effet c'est la première montée sur des
marches bien taillée
à l'ombre du rempart l'effort passe tout
seul sinon les pauses seront les
bienvenues pour en apprendre un peu plus
sur cette espèce endémique très présents
dans cette zone le tan rouge faut savoir
que le thon rouge c'est un arbre qui a
été utilisé a longtemps peindre le linge
blanc ont coupé des petites tranches de
bois on mettait ça à tremper dans de
l'eau et ça va libérer son talent un
rouge d'où le terme tan rouge teint
rouge pour découvrir la couleur rouge on
gratte un petit peu les corses et vous
allez avoir la sève tout rouge qui sort
directement et qui vous tient là la peau
de rouge vin rouge sang un rouge vermeil
c'est vraiment ce pigment là quand on
met dans le dans l'eau il va être libéré
et un le linge directement
la montée terminé le sentier serpente à
flanc de remparts attention à bien
vérifier l'état du sentier avant de
partir car sur cette zone du quart des
gaines les éboulis sont fréquents se
sentent il faut savoir que ça a été
coupée par un éboulis qui n'est pas
qu'il n'est pas très loin donc du coup
on a fait une déviation pour pas perdre
le sentier des choses qu'on a
actuellement sur cilaos pratiquement
tous les sentiers de ce secteur sont
collé à la paroi du québec m à chaque
fois qu'on a un glissement de terrain
bon les sentiers sont là donc c'est le
cas ici actuellement pour le sentier des
sauces et c'était aussi le cas à une
époque pour le sentier du québec guen
avec un glissement de terrain qui a
coupé le sentier lourde du passage de
gamède en 2007
le sentier continue lentement direction
de bras sec le passage sur un autre
versant permet de découvrir un beau
point de vue sur une partie du village
au dessus c'est le bonnet de prêtres qui
domine et en contrebas la forêt de
cryptomerias
saoulé cryptomérias l'ambiance change du
tout au tout
seuls les longues aux pestes végétales
parmi les plus virulentes semble pouvoir
y pousser
rapidement le sentier ressort de la
forêt dans une clairière où ont été
replantés des espèces endémiques
on est dans une clairière info faut
imaginer qu avant 2002 avant le cyclone
dean à la zone où on se trouve était
envahi par des cryptomérias dina est
passé le cyclone tropical intense est
passé a tout détruit à tout casser les
bois dans ce secteur donc le hénaff a
décidé d'arracher les plans de
cryptomérias détruits et revenir
replanter restructurer cette forêt en
espèces à endémique à de la réunion
notamment là on voit le maho le tamarin
des hauts le changer corse et tout ça ça
va pousser on va essayer de retrouver
une nes une espèce primaire qu avait
autrefois le secteur de brasser
en quelques passes et l'arrivée à bras
sec au niveau du stade la route est
juste là il faudra la remontée sur
environ 300 mètres pour retrouver notre
point de départ
se sentir à ce que j'aime c'est déjà la
quantité d'espèces endémiques qu'on
trouve dans ce secteur ce que j'aime
bien c'est le bois de thon rouge le tan
rouge là où avec ses figures imposant
c'est l'un des endroits où j'ai vu les
plus gros et les plus grands tan rouge
sur cilaos ce que j'aime aussi sur ce
sentier c'est les points de vue qu'on
arrive dès qu'on a fini le sentir on a
un super point de vue sur cilaos et le
village de bras sec le bonnet de prétend
entre un sentier court facile accessible
à tout le monde surtout en week-end si
les gens à dimanche après midi ou un
samedi après-midi veulent fait une
petite balade avec les enfants
posent des temps prendre le bon air
finir web peu les plantes endémiques de
la réunion ils peuvent faire ce sentier
là c'est accessible à tout le monde très
très très court moins d'une heure de 7 à
77 ans il n'y a pas de souci puisque
j'aime moi un peu après la sueur sur ce
sentier c'est notamment avec ses
cryptomérias qui donne des racines de
surface est pas content quand on
commence à marcher c'est hyper glissant
donc faudra faire extrêmement attention
les racines de cryptomérias sont hyper
glissante et si on fait pas attention on
part en part vita à la renverse quoi